well we are thinking if it's possible to
have children we're talk thinking about
having a baby we're discussing it
David and I have been talk you know on
and off about uh having shop but kids
have not been my priority for a long
time but least at least something feel
different looking after Amber and Jordan
I I don't know I just feel like I really
want to have one of my own how many kids
you have before three oh okay uh-huh
but I've had a vasectomy 22 years ago
because sometimes I can't go like for
three months I didn't have my period
every three months
do you check the this problem before yes
she has PCOS
honestly in my health I always has a
problem with my woman part and uh David
took me to the doctor a couple years ago
and we found out I have a p c o s
um
PCOS is an imbalance in hormones and it
can cause mood swings weight gain hair
loss and have irregular periods
right now I am taking the medicine for
PCOS
and I'm not really sure that's going to
affect my ability to have a baby
and that is what I want to find out
today maybe we'll check pap smear first
okay
[Music]
I need to check inside okay
and pay attention on the screen better
to see relax yourself hello
this is in size
this is a womb can you see uh-huh
this is a PCO right because of it have a
lot of it
the womb is okay
baby House Fine
easy finish okay
yeah
foreign